Traduttore: Elena Entradi
Revisore: Beatrice Chiamenti
Buongiorno.
Grazie.
Partirei da questa prima immagine
che è passata
che mi ritrae ancora molto piccolo
intento a disegnare.
In effetti quando mi chiedevano
cosa avrei fatto da grande
rispondevo senza esitazione:
il disegnatore.
Sicuramente mio padre
deve averci messo lo zampino
perché lui era pittore
e si respirava aria artistica in casa.
Però è con i primi fumetti
che ho avuto una vera illuminazione.
Leggevo tantissimo le mie storie
e i miei autori preferiti.
Mi appassionavo alle storie
ma anche ai disegni
che osservavo
e cercavo di codificare
e capire quali erano i segreti
di chi reputavo i maestri del disegno
ancora più di quelli
che mi insegnavano scuola.
Cercavo di disegnare
e riprodurre quello che vedevo.
Gli anni della scuola
sono stati importanti
perché mi mettevo sempre in ultima fila
e scarabocchiavo tutto il tempo.
Gli insegnanti spesso mi assecondavano,
perché mi vedevano appassionato
e mi lasciavano fare
a patto che non disturbassi,
anzi spesso mi incoraggiavano
e questa è stata
una bella palestra per me.
Dopo la scuola sono passati tanti anni
e c'è stato il servizio militare.
Anche lì avevo sempre in testa
di disegnare fumetti,
macinavo veramente tanti disegni.
Ho avuto la fortuna
di imbattermi in un ufficiale
che aveva una certa sensibilità
per il disegno
e che visti i disegni che facevo
mi ha commissionato delle illustrazioni
per il calendario della caserma
in cui dovevo disegnare
dei cannoni da artiglieria pesante
che non era esattamente
ciò che volevo fare nella vita
ma che ho fatto
con tutto l'impegno possibile.
Il comandante fu soddisfatto del risultato
e mi commissionò una serie di ritratti
per lui, la moglie e per tutti i parenti.
In sostanza, quell'anno
ho solo disegnato.
Dopo c'è stata l'università.
L'università mi interessava da un lato
ma mi preoccupava anche,
perché rischiavo di non avere tempo
da dedicare alla mia passione.
Vedevo che erano passati tanti anni
ma non avevo concluso niente,
quindi ho preso l'iniziativa
ho presentato alcuni lavori all'editore
che pubblicava i miei fumetti preferiti
la Walt Disney.
Qualche settimana dopo
sono stato contattato per un colloquio
e sono partito per Milano,
dove mi ha ricevuto Giovan Battista Carpi
un mitico disegnatore
della scuola disneyana
di cui avevo letto praticamente tutto
e conoscevo bene lo stile,
l'incontro con questo maestro
è stato molto emozionante.
Ricordo che quella volta
gli portai dei disegni
che lui iniziò a scrutare attentamente
senza dire una parola.
Poi si alzò e se ne andò
dicendomi di aspettarlo.
Stetti lì ad aspettarlo per molto tempo,
penso più di mezz'ora
e ricordo che fantasticai molto,
pensai di poter cominciare finalmente
a disegnare a livello professionale.
Però cercavo di moderare i miei pensieri
tornando alla realtà,
pensando che forse
non era ancora tempo,
forse il mio stile non era
ancora abbastanza maturo.
Comunque tornò il maestro con in mano
un plico di fogli e me lo diede.
Io vidi che si trattava
della prima sceneggiatura di un fumetto.
Quello è stato uno dei momenti
più emozionanti della mia vita
perché fino ad allora non avevo
fatto altro che sognare
e disegnare mentre sognavo.
In quel momento si concretizzava
il sogno di tanti anni.
Era la prima sceneggiatura.
Seppi poi che il maestro
era stato via più di mezz'ora
per convincere il direttore
a darmi quella storia
investendo in un giovane senza curriculum
o esperienza professionale.
Per me questa fu
una dimostrazione enorme di fiducia
che poi cercai di ricambiare con i giovani
che mi si sono presentati negli anni,
giovani meritevoli
che mi hanno mostrato i loro lavori.
Questo è lo spartiacque
dal periodo di dilettante
a quando sono diventato professionista.
Però non sono diventato professionista
in automatico, ero ancora dilettante
ma dovevo dimostrare di saper fare
certe cose a livello professionale.
In questo mi aiutò il mio maestro,
che mi seguiva e aggiustava i miei disegni
e poi mi venne in aiuto
la mia sfacciataggine dell'epoca
perché quando si è così giovani
non ci si fanno troppe domande.
Così iniziai a macinare un'infinità
di storie, a disegnare tantissimo
a quel punto potevo migliorare
molto più velocemente,
non c'erano i freni della scuola
o del servizio militare
lo stile evolveva molto rapidamente.
Quel periodo è stato quello
della mia vera formazione,
scoprivo nuovi autori e nuove modalità
di disegno, mi confrontavo con i colleghi.
È stato un periodo molto fertile.
Soprattutto scoprivo cose interessanti
fuori dal panorama fumettistico.
Fino a quel momento avevo
come punto di riferimento pochi autori,
il mio stile risentiva
di quelle influenze.
Adesso cercavo di aprire il ventaglio
delle conscenze
e scoprivo autori interessanti
fuori dal mondo del fumetto.
Ad esempio nel mondo del cinema,
nella pittura,
nel mondo della fotografia.
In questo modo mi allontanavo dal fumetto
e scoprivo nuove cose entusiasmanti
e prestavo meno attenzione alla lettura
dei fumetti, la mia passione originaria.
Però in qualche modo i nuovi interessi
riconfluivano nel fumetto.
Per esempio mi interessava la fotografia
e cercavo di fare degli scatti
con inquadrature particolari
che potessero essere rese
nelle vignette di un fumetto.
Mi appassionavo anche di architettura
e anche quella tornava nei fumetti.
Edifici eclettici o strambi potevano
trovare spazio nelle storie che facevo.
Anche il cinema offre
molti spunti utili per il fumetto,
il cinema e il fumetto sono complementari
e si aiutano a vicenda.
In quegli anni il mio fumetto
si è arricchito
delle mie esperienze e del mio vissuto
che entrava nelle storie
anche se più avanti ho capito
che molte cose che ci appartengono
devono entrare di nascosto
nelle storie che facciamo
perché se la citazione o il gesto
autoreferenziale è troppo evidente
può disturbare chi legge
o non essere troppo elegante.
Un autore di fumetti,
come chiunque faccia un lavoro creativo,
deve cercare di farlo
con vitalità ed entusiasmo
ed evitare di cadere
nella routine o, peggio, nella noia.
Io adotto un piccolo espediente:
mi piace mettermi alla prova
con cose nuove.
Quando ho lavoretti meno importanti di
quelli soliti per le grandi case editrici
li accetto volentieri
perché mi mettono alla prova
mi spingono a spremere le meningi
e riflettere su cose nuove.
Da un lato richiedono
uno sforzo maggiore
e producono dei risultati inferiori
perché non si è raggiunta
una perfezione formale,
ma danno grande soddisfazione
quando uno alla fine ce la fa
ed è un esercizio molto utile.
Se guardiamo la parabola creativa
di molti artisti
notiamo all'inizio un periodo
di evoluzione
che spesso porta a livelli molto alti,
fino a raggiungere una perfezione formale.
Fin qui tutto bene.
Poi si rischia di cadere nella routine,
la ripetizione dei modelli acquisiti
con fatica, senza proporne di nuovi.
Il consiglio precedente può aiutare
a sfuggire a questo rischio.
Nelle immagini avete visto dei lavori
che ho fatto in questi ultimi anni
riferiti soprattutto alle storie Disney,
ma non solo, ci sono anche tavole
per il mercato francese,
che sono in uno stile
chiamato semi-realistico,
non così umoristico
come quelle disneyane.
In Francia esiste un mercato
importante di fumetto,
che è considerato come
una forma d'arte a tutti gli effetti.
I volumi a fumetti vengono rilegati
e proposti in libreria
come i libri di letteratura,
le tavole a fumetti vengono esposte
in grandi musei come il Louvre.
Avete visto tavole
fatte per l'editore Bonelli,
famoso in Italia per le serie
Tex e Dylan Dog
e una serie di lavori per editori minori
non destinati al grande pubblico
che spesso proprio per questo danno
più possibilità di movimento agli autori
perché non hanno i vincoli stretti
delle grandi case editrici.
Concludo il mio intervento
riagganciandomi
al tema del TEDx
di quest'anno: "Let's play!"
Per me: come possiamo giocare
col nostro mestiere.
Il mio maestro diceva che è importante
avere in testa una cosa
cioè che noi lavoriamo
per far divertire il nostro pubblico
cioè quello dei ragazzi e dei bambini.
Questo penso che sia fondamentale.
Non dobbiamo abbandonarci
al nostro personale divertimento
ma dobbiamo sempre stare attenti
a chi c'è dall'altra parte.
Questo ragionamento
può essere capovolto.
Un autore deve divertirsi
in prima persona
per poter far divertire
chi usufruisce del suo lavoro.
Un autore annoiato non trasmette
gioia e divertimento a chi legge.
La soluzione ideale è quella
di rimanere sospesi in bilico sul crinale
dove convivono gioco,
divertimento e professionalità.
Non so se ci son riuscito,
a volte sì a volte no
ma quando qualche lettore mi ha detto
che si era divertito a leggere una storia
e io sapevo che nel farla mi ero divertito
questo è stato il momento
di più grande soddisfazione.
(Applausi)
Grazie.
(Musica)